- [Narrator 1] With 500
million monthly users,
Spotify is the world's largest
music streaming service.
- [Narrator 2] Spotify
is the home of audio.
- [Narrator 1] It's known for
its personalized playlists,
made with its recommendation algorithm.
- Think about users as this raw material,
and then on top of the data layer,
we're able to build shared models.
- [Narrator 1] But relying so much
on artificial intelligence
has also drawn criticism
from some industry experts
worried about algorithmic bias.
Here's how Spotify uses AI
to personalize users
experiences on the platform.
This is the tech behind Spotify.
In the early two thousands,
many people found music
recommendations through top charts
and early streaming platforms
like Pandora and Last.fm.
- [Narrator 3] With the
Last.fm app from the App Store,
you can listen to great bands.
- [Narrator 1] So, when Spotify
entered the scene in 2008.
- It's not so much that
they the first people
to start using analytics
to recommend music,
but it was the way
in which they combined various
computational techniques
in order to make their
recommendations feel more lifelike.
- [Narrator 1] Thomas
Hodgson studies algorithms
and artificial intelligence
with a focus on how new technology
from music streaming
companies impact artists.
- Fans who have listened
to Discover Weekly
and Daily Mix.
The way that they talk about them
is in very human-like terms.
- [Narrator 4] Discover
Weekly, you magnificent.
You've done it again.
- [Narrator 1] In 2014,
Spotify acquired music
analytics firm The Echo Nest,
which blended machine learning
and natural language processing
to build a database of songs and artists.
Spotify says this technology
marked an important step
in the evolution of its
recommendation system.
So, how does that system work?
It starts with a process
called collaborative filtering.
- Collaborative filtering
looks at the pattern,
across all of this data
and tries to understand
when do tracks happen to be
playlisted together very often?
You can think of it as building
a map of music and podcast.
- [Narrator 1] That map
looks something like this.
Each point represents a different track
in Spotify's catalog
and the location of each point
is determined by collaborative filtering.
- Which means that these
tracks go together,
according to the way
users have playlisted them
and listened to them.
- [Narrator 1] So, if these two songs,
are frequently playlisted together
they will be close to
each other in this map.
Whereas if these songs are
never playlisted together
they will be farther apart in the map.
But recommendations based purely
on collaborative filtering aren't perfect.
For example, during the holidays,
Mariah Carey's "All I want
for Christmas is You,"
might get playlisted more
frequently with "Silent Night,"
Even though this sounds like a pop song.
♪ Baby all I want for Christmas is you ♪
And this sounds like a Christmas Carol.
♪ Silent night ♪
If Spotify only generated recommendations,
based on proximity,
then users who like Mariah Carey,
might get recommended "Silent Night"
when they aren't interested
in Christmas Carols.
To prevent this,
Spotify adds another layer of analysis,
called content-based filtering.
This algorithm gathers
metadata like the release date
and label and executes
a raw audio analysis.
It uses metrics like
dance ability and loudness
to describe the sonic
characteristics of the track.
These are the results for "Uptown Funk"
which sounds like this.
♪ This hit, that ice cold ♪
♪ Michelle Pfeiffer, that white gold ♪
And has the Dance Ability score of 0.856
on a scale of zero to one.
The algorithm also dissects
each track's temporal structure.
Here's the visual representation
of that for "Anti-Hero" by Taylor Swift.
These are the beats, the
bars and the sections.
Content-based filtering also takes
into account attracts cultural context
which means studying the lyrics
and analyzing the adjectives used
to describe the track
in articles and blogs.
These filtering techniques
are not unique to Spotify,
but industry experts say
what sets the platform apart
is the amount of user data it has
and the products it creates from it.
Spotify says its content
based filtering technology
has evolved over the years
and now includes more advanced
proprietary facing features.
(upbeat music)
But Hodgson says the
danger with algorithms
is that they could
reinforce existing biases.
- This could mean that a
particular catalog of music
has more male artists than female artists.
One of the dangers with machine learning
is that as listeners start to engage
with that catalog those
biases become magnified
and that this creates what's
called a kind of feedback loop.
- [Narrator 1] Spotify says
it's research teams evaluate
and mitigate against potential
algorithmic inequities
and harms and strive for
transparency about its impact.
Another criticism is that
the algorithm isn't optimized
for new artists because
there's no user data.
This is known as the cold start problem.
Sultan says this is where human editors,
play a significant role in
delivering recommendations.
- They're possibly some of
the best people in the world
at trying to understand new releases
and culture and what's relevant.
- [Narrator 1] But Hodgson says,
the bigger concern is
that certain metrics used
in the platform's audio analysis
might be culturally biased.
- In other parts of the world,
they have musical systems
and musical cultures
that are entirely different.
- Like this North Indian
classical track for example.
(gentle music)
Spotify's algorithm labels
its key signature as E minor
which Hodgson says is inappropriate
for this musical tradition.
- However, it's still
the case that the music
that is emerging from South Asia
is being understood algorithmically,
under the Western equal temperament scale.
- [Narrator 1] Spotify
says the audio analysis
is one small part of the overall system,
which takes into account many factors,
before making a recommendation.
Some industry experts also point to issues
with how the system understands metadata
for classical music.
For example, the metadata
for a Tchaikovsky track,
can include not just the name
of the work and the artist,
but also the movement,
opus number and conductor.
Spotify's algorithm
isn't optimized for that.
Apple Music, which has
emerged in recent years
as a competitor to Spotify,
released a new app in March
that the company says is
designed to solve this problem.
(gentle orchestral music)
Spotify says it doesn't comment
on a competitor's marketing campaigns.
In February, the streaming
service joined the recent buzz,
around generative AI.
- [X] I'm X, and from this moment on
I'm gonna be your own
personal AI DJ on Spotify.
- [Narrator 1] The DJ gives
the algorithm a human voice
and offers listeners additional context,
around a recommendation.
- [X] Up next,
I know you've been on a
summer song kick lately.
- [Narrator 1] Sultan says,
the company is also exploring
reinforcement learning,
a technique that would allow
the recommendation system
to learn automatically based on feedback.
- It will help with the diversity
of their recommendation,
it will help with the
longer term retention
and we are trying to
push the state-of-the-art
in each of those,
introducing new technologies,
new capabilities and
bringing new experiences.
(upbeat music)